So now we come to the last problem of unit 6 and actually the last problem for entire course
aside from the final exam at least.
Now you have a chance to put together all of the informations that we gave you in unit 6
to create a 2-D wild fire.
We're going to be looking at a big grid of forest and seeing how diffusion, heat loss, wind,
and combustion come together to affect the time derivative of the temperature.
As I talked about before, these four factors can simply be added together
to show how T changes with time.
Let's look at the code for a second to figure out what are we going to ask you to do.
As you can see, they've given you a number of different constants
that are going to help you out a lot.
One thing that's kind of a small detail that maybe interesting to know
is that the velocity due to the wind, which we can see right here, is actually very low.
It's much lower than the velocity of the wind itself since the fire is only going to follow the wind
at a fraction of the wind's real speed.
As I said earlier, your first task is going to be to take into account heat diffusion,
heat loss, wind, and combustion in the 2-D heat equation right here.
Fortunately, we're not going to ask you to use the implicit method that you used in homework 1.
You can just use the explicit method you used before so basically the forward Euler method.
And important thing that we need to deal within this problem is especially the varying conditions.
We must be careful to not introduce any hard edges anywhere, or they will probably lead to artifact.
First in the solver to the huge values in the derivative and second in terms of the model itself.
We want to make sure that we don't see any staircases or pixelated contours
or really anything that does not look like reality.
To help deal with this, we have already included a smooth calcium bell shaped
for the initial distribution of the temperature.
The second thing that you need to do, however, is to create an initial distribution for the wood density.
Now, I'll give you a little bit more information about that right now.
Remember the grid that we're creating using the code
is basically making a map of the terrain that we're looking at.
This graph right here is going to give you an idea
of what we are looking for in terms of wood density distribution.
Now here we have a bunch of lines that are parallel to one another but slightly displaced.
X and y are actually just the physical coordinates that we are looking at.
But the different colors of the different lines correspond
to changes in the wood density at each location.
So every point along the blue line is going to have the same density as every other point on that line.
Every point on this purple line has the same density and so on and so forth.
In the code, we created 2 constants for you, wood 1 and wood 2 which have underscores in the code.
That would be very clear what they are referring to.
In this mark out, the highest and the lowest possible values of wood density that we have in our forest.
Now, all of these lines are parallel to one another, and we've given you the slope and the code.
That means that the only factor differentiating from one another is their y intercepts.
If you make a graph of wood density versus y intercept to make something looks like this.
You can see that we are only letting wood density vary between wood 1 and wood 2, right here.
Another hint that might be helpful when you're doing this problem
is that you can solve for the y intercept of given line by saying that
the y intercept equals some y value minus the slope times the x value of that point.
So it's kind of a tricky problem but remember it's your very last one before the final.
If you have any trouble, come to forums. Good luck.